The best way to create HTML SEO
optimized websites in a matter of
minutes is now officially open. Rank
site has launched and in today's video
we'll be doing a full walk-through. I'll
also be sharing our early adopter beta
launch week discount. Let's go ahead and
get started. So first you want to sign
up for rank site. There's going to be a
link in the description below today's
video. Make sure you click that link
because it will get you an exclusive
discount on our very very limited
lifetime deals. So the first thing we
want to do is obviously go ahead and
create an account. Very very simple and
easy to do. Then you're going to choose
the type of site that you're building.
Currently we have the templates for
local service business, for
tradespeople, contractors, local service
providers, uh window cleaners, roofers,
plumbers, any local service business
would do well for this specific
template. We do have other templates
coming soon that will be a little bit
more general, but you can actually use
this local service business for general
websites as well. So we're going to go
to continue and then we're going to fill
out our business name and business
information. So we've entered in our
business information. We just made up a
business, but of course you'd want to
enter it as your own information or the
local business that you're building this
website for. So business name, business
phone number, which city you're in,
state or province, and then your
tagline, which is going to be under your
header. So about a couple of sentences
works really really well.
We're going to go to continue and then
what you can do is you can copy over
this prompt here. We're going to make it
easy for you to just copy over the
prompt, put it into a tool like ChatGPT,
or um any AI tool and just copy over all
of the information here, and then just
paste it in. So what services you offer,
um which locations you service, what
makes you different, so on and so forth.
So this is going to help the AI
understand your business a little bit
better. So the AI uses information
directly when writing your pages. So
make sure you're adding as much
information as you can. And then Now
going to enter in the services that
this business does. So for example, this
is a business that does residential
lockout service.
So we're going to paste that in there.
Then we're also going to paste in lock
rekeying.
Right, so we've added in four services,
but of course you can add as many as you
like. And then we're going to enter
enter the areas or the service areas
that this business um services. So
again, you can add as many or as little
service areas as you like. And then
we're going to go over to continue. So
now we can upload our logo. So I think
we actually told ChatGPT to create a
logo. So I'm just going to download this
logo quickly here. And then we're going
to upload this logo. We're also going to
choose our brand color. So you can
choose um a couple different colors here
or you can enter in a custom color. So
for example, I can take a custom
So I can take a custom code for a color
and we can use that as our brand color.
So we want it to match our logo
obviously so it looks a little bit
better. So then we're going to go over
to continue.
Now, here's where we can add in our
contact form. I recommend you do this at
the beginning because
it allows you to have a form that works
well.
And this is going to be very very
important. So you can use Formspree.
Formspree is very very easy to use. All
you need to do is add new, click new
form.
We're going to do a test form. And then
we're going to click create form. And
you simply go over and copy over your
form. And on the back end we will set up
the fields for your form. Your form is
going to have uh the full first name,
last name, phone number, things of that
nature and the services that they're
included um or they're interested in. So
everything will be set up. All you need
to do is essentially create a skeleton
form with a endpoint URL and you paste
that in that you can use a variety of
different form services. I just use
Formspree, but you can use a different
form service if you'd like. And then we
can see our build. So we see the
business name, phone number, email
address, about us, services structure,
so on and so forth. Now, very, very
important, we need to add in our own
OpenRouter API key. Now, if you don't
know what OpenRouter is, it essentially
is a uh a unified interface that allows
you to get one singular API, and you can
use a variety of different um
models. So, you can see here, you can
use GPT-5, we can use Grok, we can use
Claude Sonnet,
um whatever model you'd like to use. So,
just head over to OpenRouter. If you
haven't created account, you then you
need to add $10 of credit on your
OpenRouter API key, and then this will
give you um if you go over the APIs, you
can create a new API key. Right? So,
once you add 10 bucks, then you'll have
your API key, and you can use that to
generate your pages and your blog post,
and $10 will allow you to create at
least 30, 40 uh pages on your website.
So, it goes a very long way, but you
control the cost, and you can create as
many pages, as many blog posts, and
really automate your website for the
lowest price possible using your own API
key. So, that's why we've decided to use
your own API key, because it keeps the
cost lower for you. So, I'm just going
to copy over our API key here, click
validate and save. It's going to
validate.
Now, everything is good to go.
So, there's two main things we can do
here. We can generate our first look of
our website uh with AI,
or we can go manually over to our
dashboard, generate each pages, and then
generate the full um website. Just so
that we can get a very, very quick look
at what the site looks like, I'm going
to publish this. And this is very, very
impressive, because I've used some other
AI website building tools,
and it takes you sometimes hours to
generate a website. As you can see here,
we just generated a website within what,
less than 5 minutes? Right, it has our
own unique information and it also has
our form embedded and it has our own
subdomain as well. So, we can see that
this is the
dummy of our site right now, right? We
haven't done a lot of work, but it looks
pretty good, right? As you can see, we
can see our services, so these are the
services in which we chose. We can even
click onto these services. It's going to
have just placeholder content for now,
but like it gives you a really really
good idea
of what your website will look like and
it's already coming along pretty well.
We have our hero with our form and our
form is actually working as well. So, if
I go here
and I click
call for a free quote, we can see the
form was successfully submitted. Right?
So, our form is working. We see our
services. If we click into any of one of
these, you can also see that our URL
structure is intact with categories. So,
we see we have home, then we have
services and then we have residential
lockout services. So, everything is
already set up and then we have
interlinking already in the sidebars as
well. So, we can go from one services
over to the second services as well,
right? If I scroll down, we can see
areas that we serve, right? So, we can
see that these areas that we serve has
already been generated as well, right?
So, lock keying in South Tampa, lock
keying in uh Tampa, Florida,
right? Um lock keying in Brandon, right?
So, we see here
and we see that every single page is
interlinked and everything has very very
strong SEO from us just generating a
website in a couple of minutes. Very
very impressive and there's no other
tool which does this at this lightning
speed. Then we have why use us, we have,
you know, some key components of our
business and we can everything here is
customizable, how it works. And then we
have our map here. So, probably serving
and then we have the locations that we
serve. Now, if everything here looks a
little bit generic or plain, we're going
to be able to customize every single
thing here once we go back over to our
dashboard.
Right? But again, a very very good start
of a SEO and geo-optimized website in a
couple of minutes um just from including
our business information. So, now let's
go back over to our dashboard.
And this is where the fun really really
happens. So, we can see the full website
here has been generated.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm going
to generate our home page with AI. So,
essentially what we need to do is we
just need to be able to edit our home
page. So, just give it a couple of
seconds to do so. And then I'm also
going to do the same for our residential
lookout service.
And I'm going to do the same for our
location. So, residential lookout
service in Tampa.
Right? So, I want to generate one
service and one location page. But you
can actually generate as many pages as
you like simultaneously. So,
as we can see here, there's a couple of
different buttons. We can add a new
page.
We can publish our full site.
Or we can generate all pages with AI.
Now, I would say just hold off on
generating everything with AI at once.
You want to make sure, you know, your
website and stuff is building in a very
organic way um especially if you have
your own custom domain. So, just hold
off on actually generating everything at
once. But as we can see here,
our content is going to start generating
and it's using our open AI API keys. So,
we see the home page is not ready. So,
we can actually go ahead and edit our
home page. So, what it generated was it
generated more um more customizable FAQs
that's relevant to our specific
business. So, the FAQs here was kind of
vague and generic, but as we can see
here, this information is a little bit
more in-depth and relevant to our actual
business. And then we have our him
images. So, on the right-hand side here,
we can actually update all of our home
page images. And this is where it gets
really, really fun. So, instead of
having a blank screen here, we can add
an image. So, I I I can go to a choose
image,
and there's three main ways in which I
can upload images. I can choose from my
library, but that means I already have
to have images. I can upload images, or
I can generate images. Now, if I'm
generating images, it's going to use my
Open Router API as well to then generate
images using my one API key. So, I'm
just going to enter in my prompt of what
the image I want it to be. So, I want a
technician doing a residential key
replacement service in Tampa, Florida.
So, that's going to be my prompt. Of
course, you can improve it as much as
you like, and just send that over, and
within a couple of minutes as well,
images obviously take a little bit
longer, that will also be created. Let's
go back over to our pages, and we can
see here that our residential lockout
service has been generated. So, if we
take a look, we can see the slug looks
really, really good. We see the H1,
we see the content here. We have
highlight cards in which we can change.
We have our FAQ.
We have our SEO,
um meta title and meta description. Now,
if we scroll down to the bottom here, we
can see our schema.
So, our service schema was detected, and
our schema has actually been generated
onto this page. Very, very, very, very
important, because every single one of
our pages has its own schema markup. So,
it's going to be optimized and improve
the likeliness that it gets indexed, it
gets ranked, and it shows up in AI
search.
And you don't have to do anything
additional. It does it all directly for
you. So, I can save this as a draft, or
we can go ahead and publish this.
Now, let's go ahead and take a look at
our other page. This was the location
page. So, we see this is a service page
where we just looked at, and now this is
a location page. We can go ahead and
edit this page as well.
And again, we have our HTML element. So,
residential lookout services in Tampa,
quick facts, everything here is
optimized for SEO and GEO, and is also
going to include your business
information.
Right? So, we see the city, we see the
FAQ section,
we see the SEO section, and we also see
our location business type schema is
included as well. Right? So, it saves
you a bunch a bunch of time.
Now, we can go ahead and also publish
this page. Now, we all know that
creating pages on a website doesn't mean
it gets indexed or shows up on Google.
So, that's why we actually have the
ability to index this page directly. So,
if I click index this page, each plan
has its own
um credits, and I will go over plans and
pricing in a little bit. But, if I index
this page, this page will actually get
published um to indexing. So, if I head
over to settings, then if I head over to
search engine indexing,
we can see here that we just sent a page
to be indexed. So, this page is going to
get indexed on Bin, Bing, Yandex, and AI
search indexing, and it's also going to
get indexed on Google as well. Well,
it's going to try to index it. Right?
Because now we know that AI doesn't pull
just only from Google. So, if you're
indexed on Bing, that's actually a huge
win as well. So, this allows you to not
only create an SEO and GEO optimized
website, but it also allows you to index
that website to to ensure that that
website actually can grow, get traffic,
and bring in organic visitors over to
your website. So, while we're in the
settings, there's a couple other things
that you can see here. You can see that
you can add in tracking and and scripts.
You can add in your Google Analytics.
You can add in your Google Search
Console. I'll probably do separate
tutorials on that, but it's very simple.
Just add a script onto both of these um
headers, and this allows you to set up
your Google Analytics, your meta um tags
for if you're doing advertising or
retargeting. For themes and branding,
you can actually go ahead and change
your theme. We have a light theme and we
have a premium theme as well. And you
can also change your logo if needed.
You can change your contact form
provider. You can edit your navigation.
You can edit the structure of your
website. You can edit the content from
the hero, footer, trust signals, um what
you get, uh grid, how it works, process
timeline. You can edit all of those
things. So, we wanted to to make it that
everything is you you can edit or
customize it to your liking. So, not
every site will look the same. You can
edit it
uh to your T for what you do, who you
service, and whatever you want to edit
on the website yourself. You could also
add in some legal pages, and then we're
going to build out team and billing
very, very soon. So, let's head back
over to our homepage,
and let's see if that image was able to
be generated. So, we see that image was
generated.
We can now add this as our home hero. We
can also add this as our CTA, and I'll
show you exactly where that will update.
And then we can also upload images. So,
for example, if I've already created an
image, and I just want to upload it, I
can simply go ahead and upload an image
from my library.
As you can see, I have two images here,
so I'm going to upload these images,
and then we're going to give it a alt
tag. So, everything is going to be
optimized. So, we can upload that image
and use it there. I can upload another
image if we need to. So, I've uploaded
three different images here. And then
we're going to publish this.
And this is what the website currently
looks like. And let's show you what the
website will look like with our changes.
So, let me just go ahead and edit the
service page. We're going to add a image
here as well. Click Click publish. Then
we're going to go to the
um residential lockout service. All
right, this is the service page. We're
going to add a secondary image here as
well. Just so we can start filling out
the website. And then we're going to hit
publish. Now, keep in mind, depending on
the plan that you're in, depends on how
much publishing you have included.
Because every time you publish this, you
have to build up the site, and that
takes us a little bit of um you know,
cost on our end to build the site and
give it back to you. So, you have a
specific amount of publishing per month
depending on the plan that you're on.
So, let's go ahead and click this.
And now we're going to be able to see
the website. But now, as you can see,
our website looks a little bit
different. We have
a image background, and I think it just
really pulls the website together a
little bit better. So, we can see here,
we have our image. It looks really,
really nice. And it's a nice overlay. If
we scroll down, we can see our service.
So, this is the service that we just
created. We can see that it has its own
image as well.
And then our first element also has an
image embedded. If we scroll down, we
can see how it works. It has a nice uh
sort of lazy loading icon. We see our
map here. And because we've now only
generated one location service, it
updates to only the ones that we've
generated. So, if you actually click
this, this goes over to the new article
that we um sorry, the new location page
that we generated. And again, as we can
see, has a beautiful overlay, beautiful
imagery here. And then it starts with a
nice uh table that's well formatted.
Everything here is um customizable
unique information to that specific
business, right? So, how to choose the
right business, when to call for um this
type of service, common residential
issues for this specific service, how
much does it does it cost, which areas
do you serve, right? So, you can see
here it's very very local specific, but
it actually uses the business
information and again, all of our
internal internal linking
is intact. So, it's not thin duplicate
content and all of the FAQs here is
actually unique as well to the page. So,
again, everything here is super super
super optimized for AI search and for
SEO as well. Let's go back to the
homepage. Right? We can see how it
works. This is our FAQ again.
Unique content, we have a nice overlay
here, and then we have our last icon
here. And again, any of these images you
can choose to have it or you can choose
not to have it. It's totally dependent
on what you would like to do. So, this
is a CTA that we get here.
Um that we can we can go ahead and click
on. Now, for services, if we again, we
go over to the services, we can see
here, this is unique to this specific
service, right? It has internal linking.
Let's go ahead and click this. Open a
new tab. Boom, it goes over to our
services, right?
It has our CTA here.
You can even add an image as the
background if you like to do so.
Signs you need this, how much does it
cost,
why choose this business, again,
internal linking is as as well. Then we
have areas we serve, last updated, CTAs,
user contact form goes to our contact
form, right? So, everything here is
smooth. You don't have to think about
anything when you're generating your
content. And again, if you click get a
free quote, that's going to go over to
your call to action. So, it's
SEO-optimized, it's geo-optimized, but
it's also optimized for conversions
because at the end of the day, if people
come to your site, we want them to put
their information into your site, and
we'll have more, you know, ways in for
you to manage your leads. And so, as we
continue to build out this tool. So,
we also have a geo and SEO readiness um
audits. So, you can see where you're
lacking and where you can improve. But,
right off the bat, from a technical SEO
perspective, you have all robots.txt,
llms.txt, everything that you need for
SEO and geo is already baked in. You
just have to go ahead and fill in the
specific information for your business.
You can also see an SEO checklist. So,
instead of us just telling you that this
is SEO and geo-optimized,
the proof is actually in the pudding.
So, this is a new site. Let's go over to
PageSpeed. This is one of our old sites,
and we're going to run a test. And if
you're running a test, I definitely
recommend running at least three tests
because it's going to give you different
um different results based upon
different factors. So, we're going to
run this test and see how it does.
But, going back over, there's a lot of
other features that we can take a look
at. So, for example, our blog features
is something that really, again,
separates this tool from any other tool
that I've seen because not only can you
create your location and your services
pages, you can also create a automated,
hands-off,
very, very powerful blogging system, as
well.
So, first, if you want to get blog
ideas, just head over to blog ideas,
and then we're going to generate post
ideas. We're going to generate ideas
based upon our actual niche. So, again,
no thinking needs needs to be done on
your end. Everything is going to be
relevant to this business. So, if you're
doing this for yourself, or you're doing
this for a client, you could really do a
lot of works I I charge a lot of money
for a service like this. So, we see here
rekeying versus lock replacement, which
do you actually need? This is a very
very very very relevant topic. So, we're
going to create a draft, right?
And then what we're going to do is we're
going to generate with AI.
And that's it. Give it a couple of
minutes and this content will generate.
Let's go back to the page speed
insights. This is our second test on
mobile where 92 96 100 best practices
100 SEO three out of three agentic
browsing.
If you go to desktop,
99 performance 96 accessibility 100 best
practices 100 SEO and three out of three
agentic browsing. I've literally taken
hours and hours working to get this
results to be consistent. So, I
definitely recommend doing a couple of
tests and if you add images, everything
is going to be optimized for speed and
for SEO and geo and this is very very
impressive numbers. Now, we didn't
mention it, but everything is SEO
optimized. So, if you open this on your
mobile phone or any
screen, as you can see, everything here
is super super responsive. So,
everything not only um is going to rank
on desktop or do well on desktop, it
also does well on mobile. So, again, you
can expect 95 plus page speed insights
on average for these websites. So,
everything from a performance or
technical aspect is there and we've also
taken care of everything from the
content aspect as well. So, this gives
you a much much better chance of
ranking, indexing, getting actual search
visitors, or getting mentioned or cited
by AI compared to if you were to use
WordPress or use some other website
builder. Going back to the blog post,
this is the article that we got back on
rekeying versus lock replace
replacement, which do you need? SEO
title, meta description generated. If
you scroll down here, our schema for the
blog post was actually generated as
well. So, we get blog post schema on
every single blog post. FAQ block has
been generated. We get a cover image as
well that's uniquely been generated.
And we get the full article. And this is
actually WordRocket under the hood here.
So, if you use the WordRocket prompts, I
didn't want to make it so that you have
to get WordRocket to use RankSite, but
we will add some sort of integration as
well. But, essentially the same idea are
the same prompts and the the the
functions in the system of WordRocket is
what we've included to make this better
and we will be improving this blog um
section to be more automated as well as
we continue. But, as you can see here,
we get a quick answer. We get a nice
stat here.
Let's actually publish this so we can
take a look at
at what it looks like on the actual
website. Going to head over to blog.
Right? We can see that this is the
blogging section. We're going to click
blog. So, rekeying versus lock
replacement, which one do you need?
So, look at this, right? Beautiful
imagery. So, two options, one smart
choice, trusted local Tampa, right?
Beautiful, beautiful imagery. Doesn't
like scream AI. We get our author field.
We can definitely go ahead and edit
that.
Quick answer. Everything is styled very,
very nicely. Now, look at this image.
Rekeying versus lock replacement, cost
and time comparison, right? Looks
beautiful. We get our content here. We
should have gotten All right, I think
maybe I just put one image. But, as you
can see here,
you can generate custom images with your
um actual article,
with your schema for your blog. And we
can see on the right-hand side, we have
our CTAs as well. You can easily scroll
between the content so it's parsable for
AI search to um to be able to to gather
the information from it pretty easily.
And then we have our tags as well,
um beautifully generated. And we can
generate any of our blog post topic
ideas. If I go back to post ideas here,
we can simply go ahead and use any of
these ideas. We have 10 articles here
that we can generate.
Or we can generate more ideas. So, as
you can see, this is a complete
platform, and we have a lot of more
things planned uh to add in, such as a
marketplace where you can add in
different apps, um
and other features that allow you to
grow the authority of the website as
well. But we're still in early days and
we'll continue to improve and iterate as
we get more feedback. So, if you wanted
to upgrade, there's a discount going on
at the time of recording this video. We
currently have lifetime deals, and I'll
be honest, we cannot do lifetime deals
for a long time because of the costs
associated with this type of software.
Because we have hosting included and
because you're building a website, um
there's a lot more cost, so we cannot
offer lifetime forever like we can do
for Word Rocket. So, it's definitely
going to be limited, but right now we
have a couple of different options. If
you wanted one site, it's a $199,
but
if you click the link below, then as you
can see, this goes down to a $130
one-time payment. So, you get a $70
discount
um in this week that we're beta
launching. So, any of these plans will
be $70 off. So, first tier is going to
be one website. If you want to add five
more sites, and you're going to have
differences of how many credits you get,
how many keyword lookups you get, and
how many publishes you get per month.
But for the most part, all of the power
features are included in most of the
sites. It's just that if you have more
sites to manage, then you'd want to go
ahead and get a bigger plan like the
lifetime agency.
And you can go all the way to getting 30
sites, right? And I think right now this
would be around uh
$429, right? So, $430 one time for 30
sites,
um and you can pretty much optimize them
as much as you like. And within all of
these sites, of course, you can connect
it to your own custom domain. And
hosting is included for all of the
websites. So, for any of the websites
that you choose, we will host it on our
Netlify for completely free as well. So,
it's an absolute bargain for you.
And
looking at what you get within those
plans, it's definitely worth it. So, if
you guys wanted to try out Rank Site for
yourselves, you can use the link in
description below today's video. You can
try it out for completely free. If you
like it, then you can upgrade to any of
our lifetime deals. Hope that you guys
enjoyed today's video. If you have any
questions, let me know in the comments
below, and I'll see you in the next one.
Take care.